YUFENG GUO:
TensorFlow.js is awesome.
Keras is awesome.
Wouldn't it be extra amazing
if they could work together?
Well, I got great news for you.
They do!
Stay tuned to find out just how
to import your trained Keras
model into TensorFlow.js.
Welcome to AI Adventures, where
we explore the art, science,
and tools of machine learning.
My name is Yufeng Guo,
and on this episode,
we're going to look at what
it takes to import a Keras
model into TensorFlow.js.
TensorFlow.js has
many functionalities,
but perhaps one of
the most exciting ones
is its ability to operate in
collaboration with other tools.
We're really seeing
a future where
you can do machine learning
across a range of platforms,
languages, and
devices, all optimized
to perform at their
peak performance
in the situation they're
most well-suited for.
The tricky thing about loading
a Keras model into TensorFlow.js
is that Keras models are
typically saved as HDF5 files,
using something like
model.save('my_model.h5').
TensorFlow.js provides a tool,
the TensorFlow.js converter,
which is used to convert your
Keras model into a format
that TensorFlow.js
can consume, which
is a folder containing a
file called model.json.
Let's see that in context
with the Keras model
that we've been using in
the last few episodes.
In the episode where we
converted a Keras model
to a TensorFlow estimator, we
also exported our Keras model
as a .h5 file, so we'll
head on over to that Kernel
and download the file
from the Output section.
So I've got my Keras model
downloaded and named it
keras_model.h5 just to keep
things clear which file is from
which library.
Now I need to run pip install
tensorflowjs in my Python
environment to
install the converter.
Notice that the pip library
name is tensorflowjs,
even though the converter
we'll use is called
tensorflowjs converter.
OK, so we've got the converter
and we got the Keras model
all in one place.
One last step before we
run the converter, though.
I'm going to create a
new folder because we
need to store the outputs of
the TensorFlow.js model files.
Let's just call it tfjs_files.
Now we can run the
converter, passing in a flag
to indicate that it
is a Keras model,
and we'll also need to pass
the path to the Keras HDF5 file
in that folder we just created
so it has a destination
to put the new files in.
Once our converter
has run, let's
take a peek inside the folder.
We see that it's got not only
the model.json file, but three
additional files.
There's a group1-shard1of1,
group2-shard1of1, and
group3-shard1of1.
These shards are here to
enable faster repeat loading
by the browser.
The files are below the
typical cache size limit,
so they'll likely be
cached for subsequent calls
when you're serving them.
So after you've successfully
converted your Keras model
to model.json, you've just
got one last step left--
got to load it into
your JavaScript.
Thankfully, this
is a one-line task.
Go ahead and use tf.modelload
to point to the URL
where you have the files
posted, and TensorFlow.js
takes care of the rest.
It's worth pointing out
here that since the model is
operating on the client
side, using JSON files,
it's not a great use case if
you need to secure your model.
For that, you'll have to
stick with client side models.
All right.
So now you're ready to
import your own Keras
models into TensorFlow.js.
Go forth and make the
next great machine
learning-inspired
game on the web.
Thanks for watching this
episode of "Cloud AI
Adventures," and if you
enjoyed it, please like it
and subscribe to get all
the latest episodes right
when they come out.
For now, try loading your
Keras model into TensorFlow.js
and see just how easy it is.